et pour évoquer les relations washington
moscou en direct à claude blanchemaison
expert en relations internationales
bonsoir toute blanche maison merci de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
la politique étrangère de washington
est ce qu'elle peut changer d'un
président à l'autre
écoutez comme l'a montré votre votre
sujet et la politique étrangère d'un
croate état ne change pas du jour au
lendemain elle est fonction des intérêts
de cet état de la perception que le
gouvernement de cet état a des intérêts
de la nation
et puis aussi de ceux de l'assurance des
lopy d'une influence des groupes de
pression et peut-être aussi de de l'état
profond ont copié sociologue américain
donc les changements ne seront pas
spectaculaires dans l'immédiat et cela
dit à partir du 20 janvier
ce sera une période nouvelle d'abord
parce que l'équipe de joe biden est
beaucoup plus professionnelle que les
réactions du président seront moins
impulsive et plus prévisibles et cette
stabilité est un atout pour les
partenaires y compris pour la russie
puisque dans le fond elle est prise de
position seront beaucoup plus prévisible
alors je crois que en plus on peut dire
que les conceptions la conception
générale delà de la politique
internationale
les deux présidents est assez différente
puisque l'équipe joe weiden considère
que les relations internationales
doivent suivre un certain nombre de
règles de règles de droit international
et aussi de règles des organisations
dinatale qu'il s'agit pas du jeu d'un
simple rapport de force
tout le monde s'attend d'ailleurs à ce
que joe biden engage un retour des états
unis en europe et peut-être pour des
raisons notamment tactique qu'il engage
une mini détente avec la chine
ceci change un petit peu là c'est la
scène internationale par ailleurs bien
sûr on peut souligner que les démocrates
traditionnellement sont plus sensibles à
la question des droits de l'homme les
que d'un autre côté ils sont très
favorables au contrôle des armements
alarme ce contrôle ce qui n'était pas le
cas de monsieur trump voila voila un
petit peu les changements qu'il y à
prévoir quelles sont
les sujets selon vous les deux sujets
les plus urgents dont devra traiter joe
biden avec la russie dès qu'il prendra
ses fonctions le 20 janvier
alors le plus urgent serait même
immédiat c'est de traiter new start qui
avait été signé par obama et dimitri
medvedev 100-200 2010 vous savez qu'il
vient à échéance 5 janvier prochain
donc dans les jours qui suivent sa prise
de fonction monsieur weiden décidera
sans doute la prolongation pour quelques
mois
d'ailleurs le gouvernement russe avait
proposé une prolongation pour un an de
manière à ce que les négociations
puissent se dérouler pour décider de la
suite
donc ça sera la première décision que
giovanni donnera à prendre avec un
retour alarme ce contrôle que monsieur
trump ne voulait complètement mettre de
côté et puis la deuxième décision
touchera peut-être à la cybersécurité
parce que dans le fond joe biden ces
jours ci a mis en demeure le président
en train d'assurer la cybersécurité les
états unis et le présente comme semblent
vouloir ignorer cette injonction
beaucoup de pays font l'objet de
cyberattaques
tous les pays sont susceptibles de faire
l'objet de cyberattaques et dans ce cas
là qu'est ce qu'on fait eh bien il ya
des pays
d'ailleurs comme comme la france qui
dans le fond plutôt que d'aller sur
l'a16 sur la place publique préfère
rétorqué rétorqué à des atteintes et
dans le fond détruire des objectifs de
l'agresseur supposé puisqu'on n'a jamais
la certitude absolue de l'origine de
l'attaqué
ou bien on prend des sanctions
économiques ce qui a été aussi le cas
dans le passé
mais dans le fond il vaudrait mieux
avoir un système de prévention
multilatéral de détection de répression
de telles attaques
parce qu' aucun pays n'est à l'attack
était à l'abri de d'attac de ce genre
j'ajouterai si vous permettez que de
sujets vont s'y marquer l'arrivée de joe
biden dans les premières semaines c'est
la réintégration des états unis dans
l'accord de 2015 sur le nucléaire
iranien et la réintégration des états
unis dans l'accord de lutte contre le
réchauffement qu'ils
éthique de la conférence de paris la
coop 21 et quelles initiatives
pourraient être prises de parts et
d'autres
plus généralement je pense qu'il ya une
sorte de consensus à reprendre la
question du contrôle des armements
puisque sinon on s'engage et c'était un
peu ce que faisait monsieur donald trump
dans une course aux armements sans
limite et danse dans ce cadre d'ailleurs
je rappelle que trump a dénoncé en 2009
le traité sur les armes nucléaires de
portée intermédiaire entre 500 et 5500
km c'est-à-dire en gros ce qui doivent
tomber sur l'autre ça nous concerne
directement
ce qu'était été dénoncée dont il ne
s'applique plus il faut voir par quoi le
remplacer par ailleurs les états unis
qui ont quitté le traité ciel ouvert
pourrait également décider d'y revenir
c'est interprété quillan leçon fabrique
de la confiance puisque ça permet à ceux
qui l'ont signé de survoler voyez dans
après avis le territoire des autres pour
voir un petit peu ce qui s'y passe et
effectivement il est dommage que ce
traité ça maintenant lettre morte
l'administration américaine pourrait par
ailleurs alors c'est un autre sujet mais
qui intéresse directement la russie se
faire une raison sur l'achèvement du
gazoduc nord stream 2 qui est tout près
d'être trash et il reste quelques 80 km
de gazoducs à construire quittant le
fonds a demandé à l'allemagne des
compensations en matière d'achat de gaz
naturel liquéfié américain puisque c'est
ça ce que veulent les américains c'est
qu'on achètent leur gaz naturel liquéfié
donc il pourrait y avoir là aussi une
évolution du du dossier puisque trump
une fixation sur nos stream 2 et il
voulait absolument pas que ce projet
aboutisse et puis on peut imaginer que
les états unis et la russie
finalement recherche à définir des
mesures de nature à instaurer la
confiance notamment en europe puisque
actuellement la difficulté c'est qu'il
ya un an un niveau défiance très élevés
et que personne ne croit ce que dit
l'autre enfin
l'actualité montre bien qu'il ya une
place pour que les etats-unis la russie
la chine et l'europe dans le cherche à
élaborer un grand projet pour lutter
contre les pandémies sans doute avec
bien sûr l'organisation mondiale de la
santé
et puis enfin les échanges entre les
centres de recherche entre les
intellectuels et l'université pourrait
pourrait se développer pour qui est
quand même une meilleure compréhension
donc on ne peut pas parler de recettes
pas ce qui est de 2 2 on ne te voit
parler de redémarrage des relations
entre les etats-unis et la russie
mais peut-être peut-on parler de
l'instauration d'un pragmatisme et
lucide
merci pour ce décryptage et cette
analyse complète claude blanchemaison je
rappelle que vous êtes expert en
relations internationales